BEDMINSTER, NEW JERSEY, LETTING
THEM MODERATE BACK AND FORTH AND
BRING IT TO YOU AS NEWS
WARRANTS.
TOPICS UNDER DISCUSSION, THE
RIOTS IN THE PACIFIC NORTHWEST
AND AROUND THE COUNTRY, FOREIGN
POLICY IN RUSSIA, CHINA, AND
NORTH KOREA.
ALL COMPELLING, ALL THINGS
COVERED WIDELY IN THE NEWS BUT
AT THE SAME TIME, A LOT OF
THINGS THAT DON’T GET A LOT OF
COVERAGE.
AT THIS MOMENT, THE MOST
COMPELLING VOICE AGAINST
ABORTION AND PLANNED PARENTHOOD
IS NOT A REPUBLICAN.
THE MOST WIDELY HEARD CHRISTIAN
OF EVANGELIST IS NOT ORDAINED.
INSTEAD, HE IS A RAPPER MARRIED
TO A KARDASHIAN WHO EVERYONE
SAYS IS CRAZY.
THAT’S NOT REALLY THE HEADLINE.
THE HEADLINE IS THAT ENCORE
CONSERVATIVE ISSUES, NOT
POLITICAL ISSUES BUT ON
FOUNDATIONAL QUESTIONS ABOUT
LIFE AND CHILDREN AND WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU DIE, NO ONE
WITH A NATIONAL PLATFORM HAS
BEEN MORE HONEST OR SINCERE OR
EFFECTIVE THAN KANYE WEST HAS
BEEN.
IT’S ALL PRETTY SHOCKING, TALK
ABOUT AN UNLIKELY MESSENGER, BUT
IT’S REAL.
CHECK OUT HIS TWITTER FEED IF
YOU HAVEN’T SEEN IT.
NOT EVERYTHING HE SAYS IS
CONSERVATIVE, FAR FROM IT.
BUT WHEN HE TALKS ABOUT HIS FACE
AND ABOUT THE GIFT OF HUMAN
LIFE, YOU START TO ASK YOURSELF
WHY ARE THERE ANY ELECTED
REPUBLICANS WHO SOUND LIKE THAT.
THEY SAY THEY BELIEVE THE SAME
THINGS, BUT IF THEY ACTUALLY DO,
WHY DON’T THEY TALK LIKE
KANYE WEST DOES?
THE ANSWER OF COURSE IS BECAUSE
THEY ARE AFRAID TO.
BUT WEST IS NOT AFRAID.
HE DOESN’T HAVE TO BE.
HE’S TOO FAMOUS AND MADE TOO
MUCH MONEY.
HE SOLD SOMETHING LIKE
150 MILLION ALBUMS OVER THE PAST
20 YEARS.
AND IT’S HARD TO CANCEL A GUY
LIKE THAT.
SO WHAT DOES THE LEFT DO IN
RESPONSE, HOW DO YOU MAKE HIM
SHUT UP?
THE SHORT ANSWER IS YOU CAN’T,
SEE YOU WORK TO DISCREDIT HIM.
HE GO AD HOMINEM, IGNORE WHAT
HE’S SAYING AND ATTACK HIM AS A
PERSON, YOU KNOW YOU WILL LOSE
IF YOU TRIED THAT SO INSTEAD,
YOU TRY TO KEEP PEOPLE FROM
LISTENING TO HIM.
IT’S AN EASIER JOB WHEN YOU’RE
DEALING WITH LESS FAMOUS PEOPLE
THINK THROUGH OUR CENTRALLY
CONTROLLED INTERNET, USUALLY
SILENCES DISSENT AT THE PRESS OF
A BUTTON BUT WITH PROMINENT
WRONG FINGERS, IT REQUIRES A
FINAL TOUCH, MORE ARTISTIC
FLAIR.
WHEN THE AUTHOR J.K. ROWLING HAD
THE GALL TO NOTE THAT BIOLOGICAL
IS A REALITY AND NOT JUST A
STATE OF MIND, GOOGLE COULDN’T
WIPE HER OFF THE INTERNET.
SHE IS J.K. ROWLING, SHE CREATED
HARRY POTTER.
SO THE LEFT HAD TO DESTROY HER
MORE METHODICALLY.
WHEN NEW SITE COMPARED HER TO
THE ANTI-SEMITES AND THEN
DISMISSED HER AS DEEPLY
UNPLEASANT.
SO MULTIPLY THAT ATTACK BY
HUNDREDS OF STORIES AND OVER
TIME, THEY ARE CONFIDENT NO ONE
WILL EVER LISTEN TO J.K. ROWLING
AGAIN.
AND KANYE WEST CASE, THEY
DECIDED TO ATTACK HIM AS
MENTALLY ILL.
YOU HEAR THAT A LOT NOW, BUT
IT’S A RELATIVELY NEW TACTIC,
JUST A LITTLE OVER FOUR YEARS
AGO PUBLISHING A PIECE ABOUT
KANYE WEST, HIGHLIGHTED HIS MOST
FAMOUS MOMENTS LIKE THE TIME HE
INTERRUPTED TAYLOR SWIFT,
DESCRIBED ALL THESE INCIDENTS IS
CONTROVERSIAL BUT THERE WAS NO
MENTION OF KANYE WEST BEING A
DANGER TO HIMSELF, MUCH LESS
MENTALLY ILL, JUST
CONTROVERSIAL.
NOT A PROBLEM, AND THEN HE
APPEARED TO SAY SOMETHING
POSITIVE ABOUT DONALD TRUMP AND
EVERYTHING CHANGED IN AN
INSTANT.
KANYE WEST BECAME A BABBLING
LUNATIC, THE KIND OF GUY WHO
POSE IMAGINARY INSECTS OUT OF
THE AIR AND SOIL SINCE OWN
PANTS, A TOTAL NUTCASE.
WATCH.
>> THE EVENT ON SUNDAY THAT YOU
SAW CLEARLY IN TROUBLE.
>> A DEMOCRATIC STATE
REPRESENTATIVE EARLIER THIS
SUMMER TELLING THE CNN IT IS SAD
TO SEE A POPULAR MUSIC ARTISTS
LIKE KANYE BE USED AS A POND OR
TRICK HIS OWN PEOPLE AND FANS.
>> A NEW QUESTION THIS MORNING
ABOUT KANYE WEST’S MENTAL HEALTH
THIS TWEET STORM AND SO-CALLED
CAMPAIGN RALLY.
>> YOU SEE THE IGNORANCE AND
ASININE THOUGHT AND BEHAVIOR AND
HAS BEEN SOMETHING THAT’S RISEN
TO THE TOP.
>> WHETHER CLEARLY VULNERABLE
MR. WEST IS TRYING TO SIPHON
VOTES AWAY FROM JOE BIDEN.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE SAD AND
CONCERNED.
HE IS IN TROUBLE.
IT’S ALSO FAKE.
THE OILY FAKE EMPATHY.
KANYE IS VULNERABLE.
THESE PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY
WORRIED BUT NOT WORRIED ABOUT
KANYE WEST TORE HIS FAMILY, THEY
DON’T CARE ABOUT HIM.
THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT THE
THREAT THAT HE POSES TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ORTHODOXY AND
THEREFORE TO THEIR POWER.
THEY DON’T SAY THAT OUT LOUD,
THEY ARE LIARS, SO INSTEAD THEY
CONTINUE TO PLAY THE ROLE OF
PSYCHIATRIC NURSE.
HERE’S THE GUY WHOSE JOB IT IS
TO GET DRUNK ON CAMERA ON
NEW YEAR’S EVE LETTING
KANYE WEST KNOW THAT HE IS
EMBARRASSING HIMSELF AND HIS
DEAD MOTHER.
>> WHAT I SAW WAS A MINSTREL
SHOW TODAY.
HIM IN FRONT OF ALL THESE WHITE
PEOPLE EMBARRASSING HIMSELF AND
EMBARRASSING AMERICANS, BUT
MOSTLY AFRICAN-AMERICANS, AND
NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN, HE IS THE
PERSON WHO REPRESENTS THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
HE DOESN’T.
THIS WAS AN EMBARRASSMENT.
KANYE’S MOTHER IS ROLLING OVER
IN HER GRAVE.
>> Tucker: HE IS DEFILING THE
MEMORY OF HIS MOTHER.
SAD.
THIS GROUP OF CABLE NEWS MENTAL
HEALTH EXPERTS MAY BE DEEPLY
CONCERNED ABOUT KANYE WEST AND
YET FOR ALL OF THEIR APPARENT
MEDICAL TRAINING, SOMEHOW THEY
DON’T APPEAR TO KNOW THAT
JOE BIDEN CAN NO LONGER SPEAK
ENGLISH.
HE IS FINE, HE IS NOT
EMBARRASSING ANYONE.
KANYE WEST BY CONTRACT IS DEEPLY
EMBARRASSING MOSTLY BECAUSE HE
IS EMBARRASSING TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
HERE IS SOMEONE WHO SHOULD BE A
DEMOCRAT CALLING OUT THE MOST
ABSURD LIE THAT PARTY TELLS.
WE CARE ABOUT BLACK LIVES.
THAT’S WHY WE WANT MORE ABORTION
CLINICS IN BLACK NEIGHBORHOODS.
THAT’S THEIR POSITION.
IS INSULTINGLY STUPID AND ANYONE
WHO THINKS ABOUT IT KNOWS THAT.
WHEN YOU LOVE YOUR KIDS COME YOU
WANT THEM TO GROW UP AND HAVE
CHILDREN OF THEIR OWN.
IT’S THE MAIN THING YOU WANT BUT
IF YOU ARE MOST CONSISTENT
MESSAGE TO YOUR CHILDREN WAS
PLEASE END YOUR PREGNANCY, THEY
MIGHT START TO WONDER HOW YOU
REALLY FELT ABOUT THEM AND
KANYE WEST HAS STARTED TO WONDER
ABOUT THAT AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
LAST MONTH ON TWITTER, HE WROTE
THAT HE HAD CRIED AT THE THOUGHT
OF ABORTING MY FIRSTBORN.
I’M CONCERNED FOR THE WORLD THAT
FEELS HE SHOULDN’T CRY ABOUT
THIS SUBJECT.
THAT’S FOR SURE.
IT’S OBVIOUS, BUT WHEN
KANYE WEST SAYS IT, PEOPLE MIGHT
ACTUALLY LISTEN TO HIM, AND
THAT’S A MASSIVE PROBLEM FOR THE
LEFT.
HERE HE IS LAST MONTH.
>> MY DAD WANTED TO ABORT ME.
MY MOM SAVED MY LIFE.
THEY WOULD’VE NO KANYE WEST
BECAUSE MY DAD WAS TOO BUSY.
I ALMOST KILLED MY DAUGHTER.
>> Tucker: WHAT WAS THE LAST
TIME YOU HEARD SOMEONE FAMOUS
SAY SOMETHING LIKE THAT IN
PUBLIC?
LET’S SEE, NEVER.
AND THEN HE WENT ON TO POINT OUT
SOME OF THE MORE INCONVENIENT
FACTS THAT THEY WANT YOU TO
FORGET.
"OVER 22,500,000 BLACK BABIES
HAVE BEEN ABORTED OVER THE PAST
50 YEARS HE TWEETED.
SEE, THE MEDIA SAID, HE IS NOT
WELL.
PRAY FOR HIM.
OF COURSE, WHAT WEST SAID WAS
FACTUALLY TRUE AND WHAT’S ALSO
TRUE IS THAT PLANNED PARENTHOOD
WAS FOUNDED BY SOMEONE WHO
WANTED FEWER BLACK PEOPLE.
THAT’S WHY SHE FOUNDED IT.
SHE ONCE WONDERED ALOUD ABOUT
THE APPEARANCES OF EXTERMINATING
THE POPULATION.
IT’S DISGUSTING.
YOU CAN FIND THAT ON GOOGLE.
WEST HAS, HE KNOWS IT, AND
LEARNING IT CLEARLY MADE HIM
RETHINK HIS WORLDVIEW.
HERE HE IS WERE A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO.
>> ONE OF THE MOVES I LOVE THE
LIBERALS TRY TO DO IS TRY TO
CONTROL A BLACK PERSON THROUGH
THE CONCEPT OF RACISM BECAUSE
THEY KNOW THAT WE’RE VERY PROUD
PROUD, EMOTIONAL PEOPLE.
SO IF I SAY I LIKE TRUMP TO
SOMEONE THAT’S A LIBERAL, YOU
THINK RACISM CAN CONTROL ME?
>> Tucker: NO WONDER THEY HATE
HIM.
TO BE CLEAR, KANYE WEST IS NOT A
NORMAL PERSON.
WE ARE NOT SAYING HE IS.
HE HAS SET OUT LOUD HE SUFFERS
FROM SOMETHING HE CALLS A
SPRAINED BRAIN.
WE ARE NOT SURE WHAT THAT IS NOT
PRETENDING TO BE MENTAL HEALTH
EXPERTS AND MAY BE KANYE WEST IS
CRAZY.
WE DON’T KNOW.
BUT IT’S ALSO TRUE AND WISE
PEOPLE KNOW THIS THAT IN A TIME